a pioneering space mission lifted off
last night in florida carrying four
amateur astronauts aboard a spacex
rocket they've already gone higher and
farther than any other group of space
tourists they're getting the ride of
their lives and raising money for
children who need help mark strassman is
at the kennedy space center where he
witnessed the historic launch mark good
morning
hey nate good morning yeah no question
right of their lives is a good way to
describe it the crew is now in orbit
want to show you where they are we're
tracking their progress as they move
more than 17 000 miles an hour and think
about this every 24 hours this crew is
going to see 15 sunrises and 15 sunsets
quite a trip and the best example so far
of next level space tourism beyond the
edge of space and into the cosmos
this is the moment our new era of
civilian space flight officially
launched fewer than 600 people have ever
been to orbit most of them astronauts
representing a handful of countries
until now
billionaire businessman jared isaacman
and his three crewmates all of them
non-professional astronauts blasted off
shortly after 8pm last night jarrod
haley chris and cyan are now officially
in orbit
it's a milestone the first time a
commercial non-government spacecraft has
taken a civilian crew into space and
orbit
inspiration 4 is now circling the globe
360 miles above earth higher than the
international space station higher than
the hubble space telescope higher than
any human since 2009
for the next three days the crew will
have some space adventure orbiting earth
once every 90 minutes moving 85 football
fields a second
this flight is part joyride part
fundraiser for saint jude children's
research hospital in memphis the goal is
200 million dollars isaac man personally
donated 100 million inspiration force
crew will also conduct science
experiments and research they'll collect
biomedical data and biological samples
during and after the flight
at some point the crew will talk live
from space to kids who are patients
right now at saint jude hospital hoping
to inspire them with the story of one of
the crew members haley arsenau she is a
physician assistant of the hospital and
when she was 10 she was a child cancer
patient herself there this crew is now
scheduled to splash down sometime
saturday evening somewhere off the coast
of florida and gail sooner or later
we're going to get you up there
oh mark got jokes this morning thank you
very much mark thank you all kidding
aside i think this is so cool that they
get to do such a big deal prior to this
the only entities in the world that had
ever put a person in this into orbit
where america
russia and china now elon musk and
spacex that is a game changer absolutely
incredible we can accomplish anything